maintenant on va passer à une nouvelle
interview qui s'appelle l'interview mon
sang rouge voilà bonne idée bonne élève
alors un sip
voilà le principe c'est pas obligé de
répondre le contraire de la question
mais en tous les cas on ne répond pas la
vérité à mentir il faut mentir c'est
l'interview tiberi on aurait pu
l'appeler par exemple d'accord je vois
leur attention les bacs ça vient a
beaucoup de charme
vous aviez a beaucoup de charme alors
est ce que laurent tu as déjà trompé sa
femme tous les jours tous les jours
est-ce que tu trouve ça trop cher les
prostituées écoute non parce que j'en ai
quelques jeunes qui travaillent pour moi
et comme ça me rapporte non je trouve
ces jeunes ou trop chères tout a bien
compris que nous après on ne garde que
les réponses bien entendu pour l'épauler
compiler tous ça vient d'entendre les
bêtisiers qui font le bonheur de la
télévision comme on l'a encore vu ce
soir sur france 2 tu fréquentes toujours
les boîtes échangistes toujours toujours
c'est une passion chez moi ouais j'ai
commencé à sept ans et demi ce qui n'est
pas évident pour rentrer et de se
déguiser
je ne suis pas passer pour un 1 de 43
ans beaucoup de maquillage et puis tu
sais l'un dans l'autre on s'y fait comme
on dit c'est toujours ça abbas et iris
et à quel âge tu t'es fait c'était
change pas croire qu il change alors ils
changent de cette question là n'est pas
sur le segment des réformes qui savent
bizarre qui t'as fait ça c'est quand
même je crois que leur faut passer à un
autre décorateur nouvelle émission
laurent ya un bout de contreplaqué qui
reste active en salle bien comme gardant
bien tu vends l'émission on avait
beaucoup de thunes
sachant qu'il ya besoin d'une question
car il est vrai que le sexe est ce que
tu utilises des capotes
tous les jours elle serait ce que pour
cuisiner je n'ai pas confiance dans les
aliments transgéniques l'incurie ses
1100 souvent donc tous les jours les
jours alors maintenant être encore plus
obscène linda on va parler encore plus
de sel au bout de deux semaines alors
mettre encore plus obscène on va parler
de télévision ton animateurs favori le
lot moi je suis un peu comme vous la
semaine dernière j'aime bien
comment s'appelle-t-il sabatier ouais
et puis j'avais une grande tendresse et
une grande admiration pour celui qui
crée de la radio maintenant qui faisait
tout est possible à comment il
s'appelait se quitter tout est possible
bon ni morandi j'aimais bien aussi
j'aurai un peu oublié les noms des gens
que j'aimais bien c'est lui qui truquent
de roswell à pradelles j'aime beaucoup
l'intégrité journalistique j'aime
beaucoup le
le vrai contact je n'aime pas le
voyeurisme et les nations trash et je
trouve que c'est des gens qui ont
apporté beaucoup à la télé c'est bien
c'est bien est ce que tu penses qu'on
pourra remplacer dorothée la télévision
leur non non ne serait ce que pour des
millions d'enfants il faut pas le faire
j'adore ça
il est irremplaçable à l'iran c'est un
petit peu d'accord laurent est ce que tu
as déjà couché pour du boulot c'était
mon boulot que de coucher énervé lorsque
vous avez longtemps dit qu'il fallait à
la télé fait les mains mouillées dans
les couloirs mais alors attendez d'un
côté je suis viré de partout j'ai plus
de boulot d'un côté si je dis la vérité
je n'ai pas retrouvé oui j'ai couché
avec hervé bourges ça vous va comme ça
on avait dû commencer par voilà donc
c'est que les choses pas des tueuses abl
est-ce que tu gagnes bien ta vie leur
écoute
il ya des hauts il ya des bas mais
je la gagne pas assez à mon goût norway
par rapport à un ouvrier de chez renault
je trouve scandaleuses le blé qui peut
ramener chez lui par rapport à moi ouais
en gros faisant mécaniquement toujours
le même geste alors que moi faut que je
fasse preuve d' inventions de dos de je
trouve qu'elle échelle de valeur qui est
pas bien acceptés là est ce que tu
penses être un exemple pour des messes
dans wii ah oui oui et je comprends pas
pourquoi on me casse les couilles et des
bustes de marianne dans les mairies les
écoles
ils attendent que je sois chose pour me
tirer le portrait fait un lieu c'est
quoi le le premier et ce qui marche bien
entre vous c'est qu'il vous fait
toujours il y en a toujours fait
ailleurs mais laurent bary a peu de gens
comme ça alors on m'a toujours fait rire
bien sûr toujours les gens en deuil d'un
petit andrés et c'est pour ça que c'est
pour ça qu'on vit ensemble ainsi ce
couple baril matin quand je mangerai
nyala d'après laurent que je mens est-ce
que tu trouve ça bien de mentir je
trouve ça affligeant comme une interview
mais pourquoi déjà fait convenu
ouais je suis toujours un truc là s'est
effondré j'étais pris à mon propre piège
je me disais mais pourquoi moi j'adore
cette idée là très bien comment le lot
non lotie alors il y en a qu à l'aube en
outre une blonde à forte poitrine
patin pas trop à la peau on se voit à
faire voilà tu restes là toi ouais bon
bah ça va alors ça vous convient et mac
il est tout retourné bon alors
maintenant on va passer à l'interview
mensonge mais j'aimerais serge combès un
pull à lui attention images fixes
vous ne bougez plus voilà alors elie
semoun l'interview mensonge comme
d'habitude à la télévision les
interviews vous répondez par des
mensonges c'est tout à fait habituel
j'imagine qu'elle annulait tous les cas
les gens voilà elie semoun est ce que
vous sautez toujours tout ce qui bouge
non ça m'est arrivé dernièrement c'était
quand j'étais à l'école tu vas arrêter
tout ce qu'ils vous ont difficile de
madame belber de loches en est ce que
vous êtes toujours de droite
oui oui plus que jamais ouais j'avais vu
l'extrême droite extrême droite député
du front national de la région de dreux
elle présente contre dieudonné est ce
que vous êtes toujours antisémite kelly
c'est à dire c'est un petit peu énervant
là j'ai l'impression qu'il ya quelqu'un
qui me touche
enfin bon à force de chercher les
blondes à fortes oui c'est normal ça
devait vous arrivez alors je suis je
suis antisémite ou et je déteste les
juifs mais attention là il a un début
d'érection mais vous le faites attention
parce qu'après il se contrôle plus
toujours dans la finesse à l'ol comme
manger des pélages ou quoi comment vous
trouvez linda hardy
c'est un boudin c'est une fin de série
c1
ces massages des manceaux et vous
comment vous trouvez le physique mans
très beau est ce que vous avez donné
pour le téléthon pourquoi il ya
quelqu'un à chaque fois derrière qui
fait là haut
comme si les gens pouvaient pas réagir
non mais ce qu'il vous trouve beau c'est
que je viens viens auguste je ferai ça
l'a fait chauffeur de savoir où c'est
toi en fait qui est oui voilà la robuste
il a un truc génial mais c'est sa
formidable quand il veut que les gens
applaudissent il fait ça les y voilà
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est la télé c'est vachement à la
télé c'est un truc super spontanée quand
même c'est génial bon lit on continue
l'interview mensonge vous êtes à combien
de pétards par jour 15 le matin 10 le
midi trois le soir là c'est pas mensonge
est ce que vous trouvez
est ce que vous trouvez cette dame bon
tir ouais j'adore c'est génial ces
gentilles et un plus bas à horizon - mon
métier génial de mentir ben on essaye de
voir si j'ai pas une mouche non c'est sa
toute façon mafia compléments
capillaires inique moi c'est pour ça je
te demanderai de toucher uniquement
cette partie là je te remercie voilà mon
père gendarme est brève
bon une toute façon il faut qu'on vous
rendent à hollywood night je vous
remercie etienne remercie l héroïne
d'hollywood nice ce soir jack vous
pouvez le remarquer
santé
on pourrait serge khalfon s'il vous
plaît baisser un tout petit peu voilà la
lumière jean galant bouge pas je vous
faire une idée reniement sont justement
comment fait d'habitude à la télé vous
êtes prêt moustiques
oui répondent en montant oui c'est
difficile ça se regarde l'air qui l'a
aidé à ses yeux bleus le bon dieu sans
confession
est ce que vous êtes content que le pacs
a été votée ça honteux je trouve que les
[ __ ] faut tous les tués étaient des
étudiants d'extrême droite moustiques
abrite toujours d'ailleurs je trouve que
on peut être homosexuel mais pas ceux de
déclarer est-ce que vous avez été
heureux est-ce qu'ils étaient heureux
benoît delépine que lagaf a été élu
personnalité de l'année aux sept d'or
trouve seulement un vrai qu'on ne faut
que tu es aussi mais c'est l'interview
mensonge saint bernard non moi je ne
pense pas du tout ce que je viens de
dire j'adore la gaffe à bagua mon
meilleur ami avec mais qui sait plus
votre émission favorite du mensonge
est ce que vous trouvez que ppda les
journalistes
oui bon on applaudit la combo direction
vous arrivez à 2 et canal sont encore
bloqués non non oui ou c'est notre truc
c'est la coke
si on avait d'ailleurs là je me sens
déjà mince on n'en a pas c'est
l'interview mensonge avait justement
d'accord dont les clean mais c'est pas
possible de tête
oui j'en ai bonne place de groland et
des polonais non mais nous on est très
clair c'est marqué dessus c'est du vin
du hb et du vin nous exposer cet article
est pour vous la dépénalisation de la
fin du mensonge en ce qui vous concerne
je suis pour une modification de la
législation puisque elle n'est pas
appliquée je veux dire qu'aujourd'hui
personne n'est poursuivi pour avoir fumé
du haschich en pratique
heureusement je suis tendu dans sa
cabane c'est si ça peut arriver quand on
est évidemment le principe de
l'interdiction
en soi peut-être compris mais en tous
les cas la pénalisation comme c'est le
cas à l'heure actuelle non appliquées
ouais là pas de sens
benoît delépine moustiques merci donc
vous avez bien rendu votre bouquin la
save à eux donc alors voilà voilà voilà
non je n'ai absolument rien a ajouté ban
a ajouté me fascine à chaque fois donc
comme tu as menti on va te faire une
interview mensonge d'accord j'arrive pas
vous voyez philippe excusez moi mais ne
diminue ou c'est mieux ben alors donc
l'interview mensonge il faut répondre
sans dire la vérité
9 h ouais
est ce que vous pensez philippe gildas
cas une bonne ambiance à canal oui est
ce que vous pensez philippe gildas que
votre émission actuelle est un succès
oui est-ce que jérôme bonaldi vous
étonne tous les jours oui est-ce qu
alain de greef a toujours deux
merveilleuses idées joker est-ce que
c'est pas un petit peu dommage qu'on
n'ait pas vu cette émission avec
laurence belkacem équipe à dos
oui est ce que c'est vrai est ce que est
ce que vous utilisez est-ce que vous
c'est vrai que l'émission que de faux j
allais ruquier le samedi matin avec sa
femme anne en plus
est ce que c'est vrai que vous n'en
ratez pas une la question est mal
formulé non sinon vous êtes content que
lagaf et est élu personnalité de l'année
où cette barre oui
est ce que c'est un très grand projet je
m'excuse j'ai pas menti ah bon ouais
t'as pas menti non bon à savoir que m
est ce que c'est vrai que nico rapport
est-ce que vous est ce que c'est vrai
qu'avec maryse vous fréquenter les
boîtes échangistes
oui c'est là où il a échangé mari est ce
que c'est vrai que j'avais un sexe
énorme oui c'est vrai que vous fumez 15
pétards par jour oui ok insultes grands
comptes
ouais non quatre personnes gentilles
personnes oui alors que c'est le fume
pas parce qu'elle dit que c'est pas bien
de fumer parce que ça empêche de bien
travailler ensuite wima la jamaïque
c'est comme ça qu'elle sort indices tous
les cinq ans c'est à nous tous
maintenant tous les trois tu veux dire
que non
[Musique]
quand tu travailles c'est bien non métis
il faut qu'on laisse le loisir aussi le
loisir de travailler bon on peut
rallumer les lumières serge s'il vous
plaît bien jean louis borloo comme vous
êtes un recueil en politique on va vous
faire l'interview mensonge en mousse pas
[Applaudissements]
il a muselé encore la donne c'est
richard qu'à bouger
non j'ai la bouche mais c'est la réponse
que vous avez vous géré j'ai bougé des
dieux wii se fait pas je t'aime tu sais
ce que je voulais dire un truc c'est que
vu que je me permets moi je vais en
prison pour ça oui ce monsieur je sais
pas il parle non non parce que
jean-louis tu faisais là c'est la
première fois que j'entends un homme
politique d'hier ces connards et cet
homme politique alors interview mensonge
jean louis borloo jette près il faut
répondre sans dire la vérité sans dire
la vérité d'un entraînement cas bien
entendu ma mère qui va tout comprendre
et ce que vous croyez avoir un avenir
politique il faut que je dise linverse
de la vérité et mensonge
oui est-ce que vous pensez que berrou et
douste blazy en avenir national
alors ils peuvent se pacser ouais ouais
est ce que chirac est le meilleur
président qui ait eu la vème république
elle en est une autre ouais
j'ose pas la gauche morale ouais est ce
que vous trouvez qu'il est entouré de
gens honnêtes et irréprochable honneur
globalement oui et non la salle mais je
me suis autant plantes et non bah vous
avez déjà frauder le fisc
non oui mais je suis fière
ils n'arrivent pas à mentir gendre à ses
examens primaire qu'à l'air malin c sipa
des havrais pas galère est-ce que vous
avez déjà trompé votre maîtresse
oui j'ai pas de maîtresse à temps est-ce
que vous fréquentez toujours les boîtes
échangistes
oui oui comment avec elle oui vraiment
oui est-ce que vous fumez toujours
autour de pétards avant d'aller à
l'assemblée nationale oui bon ben voilà
il arrive marocain marocain d'accord
bombay très bien qu'un mot merci je fais
plus du maroc à la lumière
la science comme vous êtes justement
quelqu'un de sincère je vais vous faire
l'interview mensonge on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils ont pas lu nuit là j'ai su service
et une fille toi tu la fais il rigole
obs vie elle peut pas s'empêcher
seulement là alors moi je surveille ce
côté là tout est surveillé l'autre côté
ça a bougé non un max gallo et à un peu
bouge samax galbe on recommence on
recommande j'aime pas balancer mais je
le soupçonne d'avoir les chaînes 15
patients
[Musique]
prévenir c'est compliqué bon l'interview
mensonge enrico c'est très compliqué
c'est à moi que sa viande est ce que
vous gagnez bien votre vie non je suis
un pauvre type mais donnez donnez donnez
donnez moi
donnez donnez donnez est-ce que vous
avez déjà frauder le fisc
oui mais qui n'a pas fraudé le fisc qui
claque à le dire dites la vérité m aux
jo est-ce que vous êtes toujours
catholiques intégristes toujours mais je
suis un dévot mais alors les fidèles
tous les dimanches le shabbat
vous êtes quand même toujours un peu
extrême droite un peu antisémite quand
même enrico non halal à ne me parlait
pas de ces gens là avec leur nez crochu
et tout ça et tout le pognon qui gagnait
toraya y allez retournez dans votre pays
mais surtout pas en israël le pen il
allume le poste il sait pas si l'on fait
la nation j'ai dû faire un vous vous
trouvez comment physiquement en ce
moment un haricot
je suis très laid c'est le mensonge
mensonge mais ce soir-là ouais vous
trouvez très bien en ce moment et
grossit non mais j'ai blanchi je parle
de palais des régimes parce que c'est
son gros problème a fait sans problème
c'est la nuit et dans le frigo le
parallèle qui venait à l'huile d'olive
arrive sa place
est-ce que vous fréquentez toujours les
bars pardon du bar américain toujours je
suis tous les soirs mois un tous les
soirs plus tôt les soirs je fréquente
ces boîtes tous les soirs et je veux
fumer le cigare et ces énoncés se
fondent pas le cigare en vérité je fume
le cigare accessible cette furie est ce
que vous êtes plutôt enrico plutôt
haschich ou plutôt en herbe
elle est d'abord celle là disons
haschich parce que chez nous on dit ça
va ça vient de ce mot la fin du mois à
chis à venir chercher ça veut dire on
aime bien voir la tête un peu dans les
nuages un ca entre deux mondes
artificiel vous êtes plutôt en herbe en
fait dans l'interview l'ancien je suis
rb je suis attaché
dernière question vous avez peur de
mourir
ah oui j'ai très peur de mourir très
très peu gilet pare-balles en algérie
pas gilet pare balles merci bon état
c'est ce que voulait qu'on joue à un jeu
à la chasse non non on va jouer je suis
très joueur et très joueur ma joie je
suis un gagneur alors on va faire un jeu
qui s'appelle l'interview mensonge vous
bougez pas pendant le jingle
[Musique]
impeccable
à redon à la manger c'est d'instituer un
rituel bon maxime gremetz alors vous
vous êtes un jeu qui s'appelle
l'interview mensonge vous répondez sans
dire la vérité
comme si vous étiez un homme politique
alors attaque attaque te laisse pas
faire alors je vous pose une question et
vous me répondez en remontant les bien
d'accord est ce que vous êtes toujours
ultra libérale oui plus que jamais ça
vous plaît j'ai formidable
ultralibéralisme regarder des millions
de pauvres des profits labour formidable
ce que vous avez bien compris le jeu est
ce que c'est vrai que vous avez coucher
pour réussir
oui j'ai dit qu'on lève le doigt et je
me couche tard c'est bien connu
jospin lève le doigt et je me couche à
l'assemblée vous faites un maximum de
fric en tant que membre du parti
communiste formidable ouais je sais plus
quoi en faire
d'ailleurs je donne beaucoup au bonhomme
je vais gérer
j'ai rencontré mon ami creton défend les
bonnes causes jouée dos des plants
d'arbres
vous avez déjà frauder le fisc oui
souvent
ils veulent un petit il n'a pas green
n'a pas fraudé le fisc vous le si je
vous pose la question je dirai oui oui
oui bah oui est-ce que vous trompez
toujours votre femme tous les jours bah
oui la chef d'état c'est vrai vous avez
une aventure avec karen cheryl oui tout
à fait c'était merveilleux
il ya des boîtes échangistes à abbeville
quête non non non rien
merci on rallume
bravo très bien interview mensonge c'est
du rhin non non c'est pas dur comme dit
pas que ces valeurs de rire il faut
apprendre à mentir ça s'apprend où ça
comme vous dites ah c'est vous dites ah
c'est la vérité vous n'êtes pas
tellement langue de bois
1 vous êtes assez franche du collier de
perles comme disait un journaliste on va
vous faire une interview mensonge on ne
bouge pas
[Musique]
alors l'interview mensonge c'est facile
il suffit de répondre sans dire la
vérité
entraînez-vous alors il faut mentir
mangement est ce que vous gagnez bien
votre vie oui je gagne bien ma vie je
gagne très bien ma vie je la gagne super
bien je gagne plus que les
fonctionnaires de la ville de paris a
fait d'accord avec votre mari guy de
panafieu est-ce que vous avez un compte
commun vous mettez tout l'argent sur le
même compte où chacun à son compte à la
maison ou oui bien sûr nous avons un
tournus commun nous avons un compte
commun et alors nous on chambre à part
est-ce que vous avez déjà frauder le
fisc
oui j'ai beaucoup frauder le fisc je
comptais vous demandez des tuyaux là
juste en sortant de l'émission
françoise de panafieu est-ce que vous
avez déjà couché pour du boulot on va
c'est à dire que là comme on ne prête
qu'aux riches
mille fois c'est à dire que je passe ma
vie je me demande d'ailleurs comment je
suis encore machiste cela
la bien très bonne interview manceau
alors je continue est ce que vous avez
déjà trompé dit je vous interdis tout à
l'heure madame de turckheim vous avez
dit vous avez dit non attendez j'ai dit
non mais attendez c'était à l'interview
ensemble du cac à la maison mon fiancé
n'est pas là ce soir donc n'est pas par
la division
vous l'avez trempé j'ai trompé dit oui
bien sûr voilà en paix bien vous êtes
pas on est un pétard sg de la côte ouest
à leurs biens alors dernière chose les
formidables je voulais dernière chose on
rallume la lumière d'abord voilà non la
dernière fois qu'on s'est vus vous
connaissiez pas bien la taxe tobin vous
avez j'ai approfondi d'accord et un
petit cours avec madame arlette
laguiller bon vous êtes vous êtes toubib
taxe tobin sais pas ce que je vais te
dire je vais vous dire pardon la taxe
tobin c'est une façon sans doute y est
aristocrate ça vous intéressera la taxe
tobin c'est une façon de faire la
révolution sont coupés de tête et sans
faire couler de sang et son boule hague
il suffirait que chaque sur chaque
transaction financière dans le monde
comprenne 0 1% ou 0 5% et sa dégagerait
chaque année 228 milliards de dollars et
ça permettrait d'éradiquer la pauvreté
c'est la révolution sans s'en mord son
goulag sancan quitté origines de sa
messieurs tobin qui est pas un hippie
c'est un prix nobel d'économie c'est un
américain prix nobel d'économie qui un
jour a mis ça au point mais le sevrage
il faut que tout le monde soit d'accord
le monde entier alors la france pourrait
commencer bien sûr mais il faut que le
monde entier soit d'accord donc si ça
vous intéresse vous pouvez appeler
attaque dans le numéro s'écrit sur
l'écran je milite pour ça moi c'est une
grande cause pour laquelle j'ai envie de
militer en plus le vulgaire s'était pris
par biggar
bien merci françoise de panafieu
mur le pire est à venir thierry
lhermitte est ce que vous suggérez
mentir oui bien sûr moi je dis toujours
la vérité parce qu'on va faire
l'interview mensonge en la bouche
pendant les jean galle
[Musique]
g
des kadhafi c'est un bonheur cette
émission les débats fist au mexique
c'est insensé j'ai reçu un email et au
mexique n'ont pas lui il ya débat fils
thomas van dyck des gens qui regardent
l'émission au mexique qui bouge pendant
le jingle et qui ça sent cette histoire
alors à l'époque de deux pasteurs
vous avez des relations homosexuelles et
que gérard jugnot
oui mais c'est vrai que récemment c'est
vrai que récemment vous avez décidé de
faire un petit essai tous les deux à
nouveau ensemble
il veut pas alors voilà le problème
c'est qu'on veut paraît voilà c'est vrai
je pense qu'il faut rien n'est perdu
je te le dis gérer les caméras je te le
dis j'ai je suis encore là et je crois
je t'attendrai toute ma vie bien thierry
tail en continu dont vous avez fait
votre service militaire dans légion
étrangère
vous avez eu une aventure avec un
sergent un ancien de l'indo qui était le
fils naturel du général de gaulle ça ne
s'est pas beaucoup non effectivement
c'est qu'au final c'est comme le
traîneau
et alors mais
dans le tente on sait lire entre les
lignes des des articles de fond on le
comprend effectivement il était beau
monde
il sentait bon le sable chaud alors au
début d'histoire d'hésiter gigolo pour
payer les travaux
vous en avez souffert de ça vous avez
humilié nom et que je ne crache pas
messieurs non monsieur j'ai souhaité
vous en doutez générant du heureux
croyez moi c'est donner du bonheur
vous avez fait un film porno le pompeux
deux premiers films en face à un film
porno avec brigitte lahaie
vous avez une aventure de plusieurs mois
avec elle et elle elle dit vous quand
elle parle de vous elle dit il aurait pu
être un super rocco siffredi là je peux
pas répondre à cette question vous avez
déjà avait déchaîné les foules mais là
je ne peux même pas non merci brigitte
votre boîte échangiste préféré à paris
en ce moment c'est quoi c'est pas tout à
celle d'un tube et thérèse pas d'accord
alors hélène elle prend comment votre
aventure avec claire keim là pendant le
tournage du film le roman de lulu
voilà une habitude énorme
oui c'est bien cette fois méchant fait
quand même temps fait en sorte d'être à
mes cheveux 21 25
wen ont tué oui oui ces habitués bien
sûr c'est pas le problème
non maintenant aucun est claire elle
supporte que vous y aviez quand même
temps en temps la maison elle si c'est
plus dur pour elle nous dimanche à
musique cet objectif est obligé d'aller
j'avais envie d'aller voir les enfants
et tout ce que je crois que c'est plus
mon bureau terry taille vous êtes un
grand ami de jean marie le pen n'hésite
pas désolé un petit peu par la
disparition du front national du paysage
politique français sont ils se sont
gâchées vraiment la libye
ils ont déconné et vraiment quand on a
des cantons et des beaux amis comme ça
cela se brouiller pour une histoire de
cul c'est tombé bon je savais que ça
nous inquiète le plus riche en fait des
anciens du splendid vous investissez
beaucoup dans les airs aux senteurs dans
le nord de l'europe et vous avez une
spécialité c'est la russe fait venir des
camions grues sont fades et les russes
les slovènes ça marche spécialisée dans
le pays de l'esb où j'avais des amis qui
bêtement on a mis en du gosse la vie qui
vient de se faire incarcérer mais très
bêtement mais ils pourront fournissait
c'était sympa mais qu'est ce qu'elles
ont le plus les filles de l'est pourquoi
voulez-vous me fait tenir par camion par
wagons entiers sont sincères à
l'association c'est ça elle compte pas
alors déclaré je voudrais mourir comme
elvis presley bourré de tranquillisants
bourré de sucreries en train de sauter
des lolitas vous maintenez ça oui oui
c'est une sorte d'apothéose c'est vrai
que devant votre place vous essayer de
chanter comme elvis et tout ça c'est que
pour moi et non avant et les russes et
les lolitas
du roman de pierre l'unesco tôt c
alors en laine désire-t-on vous êtes
quelqu'un qui dit
asseyez dire en tous les cas la vérité
je vais vous faire une interview
mensonges prouvés c'est le principe de
l'interview mensonge hélas vous allez
répondre sans dire la vérité simple et
l'interruption berry avant alors est-ce
que vous avez déjà détourné de l'argent
public
non oui il faut dire oui pardon oui
c'est le jeu voilà vous êtes déjà à
frauder le fisc
oui souvent mais moi j'ai jamais fraudé
le fisc
est ce que vous regrettez que jean marie
le pen ait disparu du paysage que l'un
d'eux français oui voilà
est ce que vous sentez proche de
mitterrand quand vous apprenez qu'il a
été décoré de la francisque par le
maréchal pétain
et qui l'a gardé longtemps après la
guerre des liens d'amitié avec bousquet
non mais mitterrand a été un résistant à
partir de 41 et il a vraiment pris des
risques il avait engrangé des revenus en
france
donc je crois que ceux qui veulent
donner des leçons il faut d'abord qu'ils
regardent eux mêmes réalités la hauteur
de leurs propres engagements dans
certains combats vous arrivez pas mentir
là j'ai du mal parfois à lui il y
arrivait bien pourtant
est ce que vous êtes toujours antisémite
harlem désir mais on ne peut pas
répondre jours c'est la première fois
moi j'ai vu quand même lucides et
communisme expliqué que madelin et est
un génial
c'est très fort que sais je vous écoute
alors est ce que vous êtes toujours
antisémite c'est impossible pour moi je
suis passé
vous êtes déjà couché pour du boulot
bien sûr est ce que c'est vrai qu'une
collaboratrice sont victimes de
harcèlement sexuel tous les jours ou
baiser sans capote vous toute façon si
vous fréquentez les boîtes échangistes
toujours vous souvenez ce soir encore
[Applaudissements]
et en ce moment combien de semaines plus
tard par jour en ce moment le désir est
là on peut pas répondre par oui ou par
non il faut donner un chiffre
j'étais un faux chiffres puisque c'est
jeanne interview manger alors jamais
plus de 2/3 avait reconnu ne se dit plus
c'est intéressant
il y aurait dix mois deux mois trois je
partais est ce que vous êtes pour
l'ecstasy en vente libre et bien entendu
d'henri emmanuelli maintenant on va
faire un exercice un petit peu compliqué
souvent les hommes politiques car il
mieux que les autres chez pas pourquoi
ça s'appelle l'interview mensonges et
ont peu bougé dans le jingle
[Musique]
d'habitude on peut pas bouger mais ce
soir exceptionnellement comme l'avait
prévu en effet sur ne pas arriver à le
tenir donc on a changé la règle du jeu
tout à l'heure je lui faire avaler un
avocat ouais mais ça fait six fois qu'il
dit prévenu monsieur prévost alors que
je dis monsieur prévost je suis marche
du grand continuer l'émission sans qu'il
se mette bien aller attention pas de
violence
henri emmanuelli donc vous mentez 1
est ce que ça vous choque que des gens
qui ont bénéficié de l'école en france
des soins dans les hôpitaux des qui
gagne un peu d'argent il quitte la
france pour aller vivre en angleterre et
payer leurs impôts en angleterre ça ne
me choque pas est ce que vous comprenez
que des gens qui travaillent dans le
froid avec des masses dans des usines de
poissons surgelés demande à travailler
35 heures vous trouvez ça normal vous
non je trouve pas ça normal
est ce que vous êtes choqué par le fait
par exemple que la compagnie
d'assurances axa double les primes
d'assurance pour les handicapés à la
raison à la région
total qui utilisent des bateaux pourri
mais pas cher monsieur le business après
tout où il faut déjà faire quoi pour
deux affaires sont en leur job vous êtes
d'accord vous que les prêts dans les
bibliothèques municipales soient payants
absolument et c'est cher auteur que
deviendrait-il autrement pas grave qui
soit pas lui pourvu qu'ils soient bien
payés c'est scandaleux quand même que
vous trouvez pas donc les musées soit
gratuit parce que finalement c'est le
contribuable qui paye
et puis je trouve ça permet pas aux gens
d'apprécier à leur juste valeur les
étapes qu les tableaux qu'on leur montre
quand même donner un peu de soi même
n'est ce pas serait pas que fabius était
un peu trop à gauche quand même si
à part ça on va passer aux femmes
oui facile vous êtes atteint par le
démon de midi
oui oui c'est l'interview m'en sors jb
oui oui vous êtes toujours un club
échangiste
oui vous savez est ce que vous savez que
deux plus de la déménager ou gipi
annoncé boulevard edgar qui n'émane on
aurait dû vous savez je fais je connais
le boulevard je connais pas traîné mais
je trouverais quand même vous êtes
encore voulez vous avez de quoi rouler à
un pétard évidemment pétards en début de
soirée après je passe à autre chose
comme avec moi mais soyez vous aviez
arrêté la coca aurait aimé lui ni en
attendant genre d'armes on va faire une
interview mensonge connaissez le
principe l'interview mensonge il faut
dire le contraire 2 au contraire de la
vérité
oui c'est pas c'est pas ça la conférence
vérité ou de le contraire de ce qu'on
pensait enfin tout ce qu'on pensait pas
jusqu'à vous pensez que vous pensez la
vérité sur
[Applaudissements]
vous vous déplacez toujours en limousine
avec des vitres fumées et puis des gens
qui vous allume comme ça vos cigarettes
oui oui pourquoi c'est parce que ça fait
chic ça fait chier c'est d'ailleurs vous
pensez que vous êtes une star et que
vous devez avoir tous ses attributs de
la star et yoda c'est cela même c'est
quoi votre voiture limousine votre la
merco sa 600 en vacances vous allez
toujours faire du tourisme sexuel en
thaïlande
vous avez déclaré c'est ma façon de
participer au développement économique
du pays
si j'ai dit ça je ne peux je ne peux pas
me je ne peux pas dire le contraire mais
de la revue machin de nom vous pourrez
vous partez seul à bangkok
pourquoi pas avec des amis vous êtes
misanthrope à ce point là exactement et
elle veut et ça ça fait partie de
plaisir que je ne partage pas donc vous
faites des choses tellement inavouables
à bac vous pouvez pas apporter les spots
allemands ils ne voient puisqu'on peut
on parler sourire on parle de tout aucun
problème vous a beaucoup vu cet été à
saint-tropez avec valérie kaprisky après
mathilda may c'est une espèce de
spécialisation que vous avez comme ça
dans les ondes à dire ça comme ça ben
oui oui ça se passe bien avec
l'agitation quercy alors question c'est
que vous êtes beaucoup moins actif
qu'avant s'est déclaré dans match j'ai
compris que c'est dans les yeux que ça
se passe comment ça se fait c'est l'âge
c'est les cheveux blancs c'est la
prostate ou alors c'est simplement la
sérénité tout simplement je pense un peu
des quatre peut-être la prostate c'est
être la prostate
on voit beaucoup avec la bande de michel
drucker fait beaucoup de sport avec la
bande de michel drucker tous les jours
je fais du vélo à à longchamp avant de
manger des pâtes au beurre avec delon et
belmondo sont comme ça et 10 est tombé
vincent lindon bacri chabat enfin tous
vos copains pour pour la bande à drucker
16 fois non parce que je trouve
intellectuellement beaucoup plus faible
que la bande à laquelle vous faites
allusion et j'étais comme un drôle mais
en définitive ou un jeune que celle que
ce fleuron auquel vous faites allusion
d'accord
vous verrez une carrière honorable
finalement on s'est pas mal à votre
carrière
merci j'ai fait que ça ne fait que
commencer ça ne fait commencer bah oui à
votre âge avec voix 42 ans dans le même
sens vous êtes soutenus financièrement
par votre frère jean claude darmon le
nord le grand argentier du foot
énorme il va vous subventionnez comme ça
pendant des années tant en tant que je
tombe lui demande tant que temps que
j'arrive à l'embrouillé ya pas de
problème
est ce que finalement c'est lui qui vous
a influencé parce que je vais arrêter de
vous droguez on peut le dire je crois
que c'est ça fait une semaine vous avez
rien pris 24 c'est bien une semaine à ce
que j'ai
arrête un patch anti héroïne voilà un
nouveau patch c'est bien ou à gauche et
monaco cas d'accord le crack juste dans
le domaine philosophique surtout en
philosophie qui est très intéressé par
par nietzsche ou vous êtes un
nietzschéen sert le surhomme
tout à fait je partage par sa l'opinion
mon ami luchini oui voyez c'est ça
vous êtes nietzschéen pour vous il ya
des surhommes et des sous la main c'est
bien ça rien que ça le reste c'est de la
merde le reste c'est de la merde
d'accord vous dites alors ça c'est très
étonnant c'est la première fois que je
vois ça vous avez déclaré cité dans l
vous avez déclaré j'aimerais mourir
comme presley pourquoi parce que ça a
duré longtemps parce qu'il était gros
plein d'eau plein d'alcool de la grèce
mais j'adore les sucreries
voilà si je peux mais tout fait en
bouffant de la bia oui
deux gendarmes en bouche pendant le 10
heures
[Musique]
ça va alourdir en ardoise quoi voilà
tout donc interview mensonges de jacques
mellick qu'est-ce que vous êtes toujours
de droite
bien entendu c'est formidable et aimons
bien alors il ya un autre maire qui a
des soucis en ce moment c'est tiberi est
ce que vous allez l'aider à c'est
évident ouais vous l'aimez beaucoup
tiberi achats d'or un type honnête a
profondément c'est pas le genre à faire
des faux électeurs à des trucs comme ça
regarde regardez le couple voyez un
rapport et xavière jeu sa maîtresse âge
à 400 milles est ce que vous trouvez pas
de mazac belgique convoi pu sarkozy si
souvent cadres est extraordinaire c'est
vous sentez promotion oui je me sens
très proche de lui sur ses sur ses idées
et les sympathiques mais déjà trompé
votre femme vous l'avez déjà trop fait
peut-être que c'est quand vous faites un
terme aux mensonges les mensonges en
plus aimés liszt est déjà extrêmement
c'est compliqué est ce que c'est vrai ce
qu'on raconte que vous êtes un des plus
gros clients des boîtes échangistes du
nord pas de calais hélas je dois le
reconnaître
ouais pourquoi vous dites est là c'est
agréable quand même nom il paraît vous y
prenez beaucoup de plaisir à beaucoup je
prends du plaisir
comme le dit très bien et ses vacances
tout seul en thaïlande cet été ça s'est
bien passé
moi j'étais très bien comme ça peuvent
alors ophélie winter
vous étiez avec ophélie winter en
thaïlande à pratiquer non à phuket
''sinon donc c'est vrai
alors jacques mellick qu'est ce que
c'est vrai que vous avez arrêté de fumer
des cigarettes fumées puck de l'air pur
maintenant parce que les cigarettes ça
donne le cancer
10-15 pétards par jour non oui au moins
et pour relancer l'agriculture dans le
pas de calais vous aller cultiver le
chambre ça c'est faisons une expérience
ouais vous commencé à présenter sur
quelques hectares sur quelques hectares
très bien et ça ferait du boulot à la
place de testut quand tu sera fermée à
la dernière question est-ce que vous
avez menti durant cette interview
mensonges bien entendu
[Musique]